midway into the 21st season of history's
antique hunting tv series american
pickers what have previously appeared to
be a positive working relationship
between hosts mike wolfe and frank fritz
crumbled the two reality tv stars
suddenly began to feud with one another
via a series of public statements all
the while wolf remained at its helm
while fritz appeared to be no longer
welcome on the show given the
significant disruption to the status quo
on american pickers resulting from
fritz's sudden departure the question of
whether or not third host daniel colby
would remain a part of the series
alongside wolfe sooner rose as of the
january 1st 2022 premiere of american
pickers season 23 colby is still on the
show suggesting that fritz aside its
core will remain largely unchanged for
the time being notably colby does not
usually travel to look for antiques as
wolf does and fritz once would but
rather holds down the four to antique
archaeology the store that serves as a
home base for the american biggest cast
well colby has undoubtedly remained a
valuable contributor to the show for
more than 20 seasons her numerous
appearances on american pickers have
occasionally led to a few awkward
moments and one episode featuring
classic dad rock band aerosmith arguably
took things much too far
over the course of a handful of episodes
of american pickers mike wolfe frank
fritz and danielle colby began work on
restoring the first van aerosmith ever
used on tour before presenting it to the
abandoned person well the van may be a
more historically important find than
the average purchase a number of users
in a thread on the american pickers
subreddit criticize this particular
storyline for example user moneyman74
accused the whole arc of being a quote a
ploy to get ratings and do a crossover
with aerosmith opening a vegas show
the band wants to buy the van and use it
in their vegas residency are you kidding
me wow what
for what it's worth aerosmith was indeed
in the midst of a concert residency in
las vegas in 2019 when the american
biggest crew gifted the fully restored
van to the band in the opening of the
same reddit post meanwhile one user said
when they met aerosmith it was so
inorganic danielle cried and it was
embarrassing because she did little to
advance the project of the van except
introduce the original pick in essence
the post is insinuating that colby's
emotions were performative which let's
face it seems pretty likely after all it
does make for more compelling television
nevertheless colby's awkward behavior in
a storyline already accused of
inauthenticity drew attention to the
series artifice in a manner largely
absent from a normal american pickers
episode this meant the episode didn't
really inspire the kind of suspension of
disbelief necessary to enjoy reality tv
while some american pickers fans
criticized danielle colby's involvement
in the aerosmith van storyline for the
likelihood that some of it was staged
other viewers remembered feeling
conflicted about the conduct of colby
and aerosmith vocalist stephen tyler in
the same reddit thread for example user
american realism wrote just saw this
episode the other day and honestly was
kind of grossed out by how handsy steven
tyler was with danielle in the comments
section of a youtube clip of this moment
a user named john pierce posted that
they thought the american pickers crew
quote acted way too goofy pointing out
in particular that danielle was acting
clingy towards steven tyler for what
it's worth some fans of the show shared
nothing but support for colby's meeting
with tyler in the comments section of a
facebook video previewing the episode
for instance one user wrote the show was
awesome danielle you were definitely
googly eyes and thrilled with seeing
them you rock girl so it's probably fair
to say that many fans believe this
american pickers storyline was little
more than a promotional tie-in with
aerosmith's 2019 las vegas concert
residency others however appear to
believe colby was simply starstruck and
may have acted a little differently than
usual due to the presence and behaviour
of a certain world famous rockstar
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]